Was werden die man schon tun? Nee, genau, es ist deutlich gut. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO. Das Intro hast du gerade ausgesucht. Ausgabe mit Stefan Tietze. Ja, hi. Du siehst enttäuscht aus. Und Florentin Will. Stefan. Nein, ich möchte das kurz ein wenig erklären. Und zwar hat Julian dieses Intro uns geschickt mit einem Begleittext. Und zwar geht es hier um den Vorfall, der sich zugetragen hat, als du jäh ein Taubenleben beendet hast. So, und ich glaube, wir hören in diesem Stück die Perspektive der Taube, die normalerweise ungehört bleibt.
Okay, mal nochmal.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Wie es geht nicht. Nee, das geht nicht. Wie es geht nicht. Das kriege ich jetzt nicht hin. Technisch oder moralisch? Das technisch. Ja, okay. Also man muss es ja nicht überinterpretieren. Man kann ja auch einfach mal stehen lassen. Ja, aber was meinst du, wie viele Leute jetzt gerade da sitzen, Mann, das hatte ich im Abi, wie soll ich das interpretieren, ich brauche eure Hilfe. Nicht, wie ich noch Tauben im Gras im Abi hatte, Tauben vom Auto. Ist der neue Track, den ihr jetzt bald mal analysieren müsst. Wer ist das eigentlich, der hier zu euch spricht? Stefan Tietze ist sein Name. Wie hast du die Folge, wo du mich zwei Mal vorstellst? Es gibt viele Folgen, wo du es vergisst. Ich würde dich gerne alle zehn Minuten vorstellen, weil du bist ein Mensch, von dessen Namen man Gebrauch machen muss. Stefan Tietze, mittlerweile ein geflügeltes Wort. Was, wofür steht? Also es ist nicht mehr geflügeltes Wort. Und ich bin Florentin Will, herzlich willkommen in dieser neuen Ausgabe, in der wir unsere Namen nennen. Das ist die Grundlage dieses Podcast-Projekts, weil wir haben ja gesagt, Stefan, wir wollen uns mal zusammensetzen und unsere Namen sagen. Ja, gerne Namen sagen. Bist du zufrieden mit deinem Namen eigentlich? Habe ich dich noch nie gefragt, obwohl Florentin heißt, was ein so spezieller Name ist. Ach ja, geht. Das ist manchmal so, wenn man so Wörter hat, die man manchmal zu viel im Mund hatte, die dann so ein bisschen abgeschmackt sind. So ist es manchmal so ein bisschen. Aber nee, geht schon. Das ist natürlich, gerade so in dieser YouTube-Streaming-Bubble gibt es natürlich viele, die dann irgendwie so einen coolen Namen brauchen, so einen Nickname, irgendwie die dann KXQ oder FFC oder Devil Dancer oder so heißen. Bei mir reicht es, wenn ich Florentin heiße. Ja, und auch so dieses ganze Trimax, Papaplatte, Reese. Genau, Paluten, sowas.
Ja, genau. Ich bin, sei doch froh, dass du nicht, und auch wenn du halt wie Simon, Simon heisst, musst du ja auch was mit dem Namen machen und so. Du kannst einfach nur den scheiß, kack, einfachen Dösel Florentin-Namen nehmen. Das heißt dann, hier ist Paluten, Papa Platte, Baso und Florentin Will. Kevin. Ja, bin ich. Nee, ist schon okay, kein Problem. Cool. Aber es gibt auch noch viele, die Florentin sagen. Florentin? Das ist auch okay, ja. Es gibt viele, die mich mit FF schreiben. Ja? Stefan, also mit zwei F. Wieso das denn, so wie Steffen oder was? Also es gibt so eine wieder natürliche Schimäre aus Steffen und Stefan. Es gibt viele, viel mehr Menschen, die mich Stefan mit zwei F schreiben. Ich glaube, weil du immer Stefan sagst. Wie heißt er Stefan? Ja, Stefan. Aber es klingt nach zwei F. Mehr schreiben mich Stefan mit zwei F als mit PH. Ah, okay. Alles klar. PH ist unter zwei F. Das ist wieder so eine Wette. Wir sagen das und man muss raten, ob es mit F oder PH gesprochen wird. Okay. Stefan Tietze aus Karmene wettet, dass er den genannten Namen Stefan so interpretieren kann, ob es mit PH oder mit F geschrieben wird. Okay. Auf der Couch sitzt Jay-Z. Wirklich? Jay-Z. Und Drake. Jay-Z, glaubst du, er schafft es Do you think he can do it? Well, I think he looks like a good kid. He's a bit older than the other children. I mean, is this a child? Is it the thing with the child? No, is this normal? No, because he looks too young for the normal thing, but too old for the child thing. I don't speak German. I don't know what this is, like P-H and F, it's something I have no connection with, so I can't really tell how difficult this is. And to be honest, I don't care. To be honest, I don't know what this show is about. I know what this is, I don't know what happens if he does does it what happens if he doesn't do it so
to be honest is there a way can i say can i say nothing can i say no is it just no no everybody
is shaking the entire audience is shaking their head 16 000 people are shaking their heads at me
right now okay then i'm just gonna say he going to say, he will not do it.
He will not do it because he's a fucking loser.
He's a freak.
He shouldn't be on television.
He has no charisma.
There's nothing.
There's no talent.
I hate him.
I hate him. I hate him. I hate him. I hate him. I hate him. I hate him. stefan mit ph richtig ja ne ja stefan was neues wort ja wieder ph richtig stefan ja elf und er Er schafft es! Jay-Z in Tränen, Jay-Z in Tränen! Oh, I can't believe it! Stand 2000 Euro. Erde. Ich wusste selber gerade nicht genau. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Du warst nicht dabei, man hat es gemerkt.
Nee, ich muss da genau, ich muss da richtig doll dran denken.
Erde.
Die Blum-Erde. Nein. Ah, fuck. Ich fand die Musik von Wetten, dass immer so toll. Toll.
Habe ich mich ans Klavier gesetzt und habe es nachgespielt, weil ich die Musik so toll fand. Das Klavier ist jetzt auch weg. Es wird alles verkauft, was mir damals das bedeutet hat. Es wird verkauft. Es ist alles weg. Du machst gerade ein komplettes Ausräumen oder was? Jahreswechsel? Meine Mom zieht aus aus dem Haus, in dem ich aufgewachsen bin. Und deswegen wird es viel verkauft, aber auch viel entdeckt. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Klavier verkauft, auf dem ich ... Dominante ... Und Gottschalk taucht auf, er taucht einfach auf so. Gottschalk wird gesummelt. Ja, hey, hallo. Das ist wie wenn man dreimal Mary Jane, was sagt man von der... Beetlejuice. Beetlejuice vom Spiegel sagt. Wenn du das spielst, dann kommt Thomas Gottschalk so. Das ist Bloody Mary vom Spiegel, glaube ich. Stimmt, der Drink. Nein. Und du verkaufst deine ganzen Sachen, deine eigenen T-Shirts, oder was? Die Garfield-Bettwäsche? Ist die Garfield-Bettwäsche noch da? Die ist noch da, ja. Okay, zum Glück. Ja, aber es wird viel verkauft, viel verschenkt und ich habe viel entdeckt. Unter anderem freue ich mich in den nächsten Wochen mal. Aber das machen wir in Ruhe. Habe ich jetzt auch nicht dabei, aber ich habe schon oft erzählt, wie ich Herr der Ringe gecovert habe. Oh ja, stimmt! In einem Alter, wo ich noch nicht schreiben kann. Und ich hätte so Nannies, die auf mich aufgepasst haben. Und mit einer habe ich das tatsächlich gemacht, die habe ich dazu gezwungen, dass ich diktiere als Kind, muss ich vorhin so ein siebenjähriger Warlord. Mit so einer langen Zigarette. Mit so einer Verlängerung. Mit so einem Hobbit-Outfit, der da sitzt und und einfach frei raus, perfekt in perfektem Deutsch zitiert, was man diktiert, was man aufgeschrieben hat. Und dies habe ich gefunden. Das hat meine Mutter dann noch abgetippt, glaube ich, auf dem Bildschirm. Also alles, es war eine große Workflow, damit der kleine Stefan der neue Tolkien endlich sein episches Meisterwerk vollenden kann. ... seine Saga verenden kann. Und das habe ich gefunden. Oh, geil. Also, wir haben alle Charaktere. Wir haben die geilen Städte, wir haben Grieria, wir haben Darkmare, wir haben die grosse Städte, wir haben den Kaiserwald. Also wirklich, wir haben da ein paar, wir haben drei Kapitel, wir haben nur drei Kapitel. Zum Glück ist der Kaiserwald erhalten geblieben. Die Originalbesch Kaizo-Waldes ist ja wirklich fantastisch. Das heißt, eigentlich jetzt ein neues Fantasy-Epos beginnt. Genau. Jetzt nachdem irgendwie Herr der Ringe Game of Thrones ist ja alles jetzt so ein bisschen abgeebbt. Das heißt, du eröffnest jetzt eine neue Fantasy-Epoche mit der grossen Welt von Stefan, die da heißt? Kronerde. Kronerde. Genau. Freut euch auf König Rasas.
Freut euch auf König Rasas, freut euch auf The Cultural Population Ninja, der dabei ist, freut euch auf die ganzen Charaktere. Aber es wurde in einer anderen Zeit geschrieben. Disclaimer. Okay, und du warst vier Jahre alt. Und ich war gefühlt vier Jahre alt. Also da freut euch drauf. Bissens schwierig wird es mit der Zeichnung, wo ich natürlich Kronerde aufgemalt habe, wo die Reiche unterteilt sind, wo der Kaiserwald ist, wo der Mittelfluss langfließt, wo der Juwelenpalast ist, die Juwelenschlucht oder so, ich weiß nicht mehr.
Also es ist noch viel, ist alles erhalten geblieben, ich muss nur einen Weg finden, wie ich das Ganze mal irgendwie hochladen kann oder so.
Ja, geil.
Ich kann es hier mal in die Kamera halten, für unsere Patreons, unsere Patreons.
Sagt man Patreons oder Patreons? Patreons,, für unsere Clubmitglieder. Ja, das heißt Patrion. Jedenfalls habe ich gefunden eine kleine Geschichte, die ich euch vorlesen kann. Da konnte ich schon schreiben, also offensichtlich war ich, es ist diese Schreibstift, die man lernt mit sieben oder acht. Aber ist das eine Geschichte aus der Welt der Kronerde oder was komplett eigenständig ist? So, nämlich ein buch schreiben ich erinnere mich noch genau ich wollte ein buch schreiben ein erstes buch nachdem das muss ja weit nach dem kronerde epos passiert sein der wurde ja auch nichts vollendet um jetzt ein weiteres buch anzufangen was ich nicht veräuft nicht veränderte eine geschichte die nicht im Schulkontext entstanden, sondern ich habe mich hingesetzt mit sieben Jahren und habe es geschrieben.
Cool.
Autor Stefan. Nele und die Nacht der Vampire.
Gruselig.
Es war einmal ein kleines Mädchen namens Nele. Montagmorgen stand Nele früh auf, denn sie wusste, dass sie heute Nacht in einem Zelt übernachten würde. Also da muss man ja früh aufstehen, ja. Sie war nämlich bei den Pfadfindern. Um vier Uhr geht es los. Dann auf einmal klingelte das Telefon. Nele ging dran. Vier Uhr? Es dann, nee, um vier Uhr geht es los. Denn auf einmal, ich glaube, 16 Uhr meine ich. Ach so, okay, Entschuldigung. Ah ja, ich verstehe. 12-Stunden-System gehabt. Warum ist sie dann so früh aufstehen? Weil sie wusste, deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum sie sie falsch steht, weil sie abends im Zelt schläft. Damit sie gut einschlafen kann, deswegen wacht sie früh auf. Moment, aber was ist jetzt passiert zwischen früh aufstehen und 16 Uhr? Nee, es geht um 16 Uhr los. Ach so, es ist doch gar nicht 16 Uhr. Wir sind immer noch morgens. Sorry, aber wann klingelt das Telefon? Jetzt morgens. Um vier Uhr? Nee, nee, nee, in der Lore. Ach so, morgens. Ah, okay, nachdem Sie aufgehört haben. Okay, alles klar, sorry. Es geht um 16 Uhr los. Okay, ja, sorry. Aber jetzt ist es mir spannend. Dann auf einmal klingelt das Telefon, Nele ging dran, es war Pfad von der Leiter, er sagte, das Lager wird auf sechs Uhr verschoben.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Fragen hätte ich mir sparen können. Es wird verschoben! Von vier auf sechs Uhr! Das ist ja mal ein packender Anfang auf jeden Fall. Kleiner Spoiler-Alert, kleiner Spoiler-Alert alert das wird nie wieder aufzubringen
und es spielt keine rolle
es ist alles weiss egal
aber der Zuschauer ist hooked
also der Leser ist
what the fuck was passiert hier
was ich mag daran
also was so Mumblecore
für Filme ist, hat das hier so
es hat eine gewisse
Stilmittel, nämlich so ein Superrealismus so ein unnötiger Realismus, warum zeigst du das, ja. Also hier Reichenitzki würde die Frage stellen, ist es ein Roman über das banale Leben oder ein banaler Roman? Ah, okay. Naja, das Lager wird auf sechs Uhr verschoben. Nilla legte den Hörer in den Ständer, weil sie bemerkte, dass sie den Rucksack für die Pfadfinder noch nicht gepackt hat.
Eigentlich müsste sie jetzt mehr Zeit haben. Können sie nochmal hinlegen, zum Beispiel, sie ist extra früh aufgestanden.
Sie sagte, ich brauche einen Schlafsack und einen Schlafanzug, Waschlappen, Zahnbürste, Taschenlampe und ein Pullover.
Dann war es soweit, die Uhr schlieg sechs. Vor allem, sie ist noch nicht da. Sie ist noch nicht da. Schlieg sechs? Das ist ja grossartig. Dann war es so weit nach dem kopf schlieg sechs uhr ich habe mich offensichtlich in der einbahnstrasse manövriert mit dieser uhrzeitgeschichte diese uhrzeiten was ein clusterfuck mir fehlen die worte zureiben, was ich ausdrücken möchte.
Ja, meine Grenzen. Man kommt so schnell an seine Grenzen, wenn man bei den sieben Jahre alt ist. Aber das ist ja die geniale Idee, den kompletten Roman zu schreiben. Nur ein einziges Mal, die Uhr schlieg sechs Uhr. Bis dahin war es ja wunderbar geschrieben, also fehlerfrei geschrieben. Ähm, nur sch- vor allem sie ist, vor allem, ich versteh's nicht, also sie steht eher auf, weil sie im Zelt übernacht, verstehe ich nicht, aber so um früh, sie muss doch viel packen, sie hat noch nicht gepackt. Ja, was hat sie gemacht in der Zeit? Bis 14 Uhr. Ist schon gepackt, aber jetzt ist 16, jetzt ist, genau, jetzt ist vier Uhr, es beginnt das Fahrplanlager. Viel zu spät schon, die muss los. Nee, es ist sechs Uhr, das wurde auf sechs Uhr verschoben, also achtzehn Uhr verschoben, es ist sechs Uhr und sie ist noch nicht mal losgefahren. Stress, Stress, Spannung. Da klingelte es an der Tür, sie macht sie auf, doch keiner war da, ausser Rauch, Lila-ner-Rauch. Nein! Doch. Purple Haze? Lilaner Rauch. Ich finde das Wort Lilaner auch fantastisch.
Schlieg sechs Uhr, aber die korrekte Form, die Farbe Lila zu adsektifizieren. Lilaner Rauch. Ausser Rauch, Lilaner Rauch. Nele erschreckt sich und sah noch in der Ferne eine Gestalt eines Vampires. Eine dunkle, schemenhafte Gestalt eines Vampires. Ach so, ah okay, da war es ja. Eines ostro-römischen Weiss-Vapiers. Ah, dann haben wir es ja auch hier. Oh, das ist ja fantastisch. Kinder haben kein Gefühl für irgendwas, es ist nur All-Nonsense. Aber es geht, es ist ein wunderbarer Spannungsaufbau, aber am Ende nimmt man es alles weg. Warum machst du es denn dann?
Es ist Gestalt eines Vampirs.
Und vor allem, also ich weiß nicht, ob es noch in die Gruselrichtung geht, aber der unbeeindruckendste Auftritt eines Bösewichts, der Typ, der einfach gerade wegrennt.
Hä, lila narraucht, ein Vampir läuft weg. Gott, ey. So, ja, also es ist gleich schon vorbei. Okay. Und was jetzt passiert ist auch weird. Sie lief nach oben in die Küche. Ach, spannend, das oben. Welche Küchen sind oben? Okay, gut. Kleiner Architektur-Tipp. auch noch. Ja. Sie lief nach oben in die Küche. Ach, spannend, das. Welche Küchen sind oben? Ja, okay, gut. Kleiner Architektur-Tipp.
Sie lief nach oben in die Küche, wo ihre Mutter sich gerade einen Kaffee gönnte.
Gönnte, tatsächlich, wo ihre Mutter sich gerade einen Kaffee gönnte.
Nele sagte, da unten war gerade ein Vampir.
Nele, geht's dir gut?
fragte die Mutter, soll ich einen Arzt rufen? fragte Neles Mutter nachdenklich. Das war nur Einbildung, meinte ihre Mutter. Ende. Das ist vorbei. Ende? Aber ist es wirklich Ende, Ende oder hast du einfach nicht weitergeschrieben? Ich hab nicht weitergeschrieben. Es ist nicht Ende, Ende, ich hab nicht weitergeschrieben. Das war es, Nele und die Nacht der Vampire. Viele Fragen bleiben offen, ich finde das Setting gar nicht so schlecht. Wir haben diesen lilanen Rauch. Wir haben die Uhrzeit, wir haben verschiedene Zeiten. Wir haben das Uhrzeitcluster. Wir haben, warum, also viele Fragen, warum wurde das Lager verschoben? Hat das schon was mit diesem seltsamen Vampir, der sein Unwesen treibt, mit dem Lina Rauch zu tun? Aber was ist das für ein Auftritt von einem Vampir? Lina Rauch, rennt dann aber weg, Vampire müssen ja eingeladen werden, also an der Tür, dass er klingelt, okay? Wie sah diese Gestalt aus, dass in weiter Entfernung sofort für alle Beteiligten klar war, es war ein fucking Vampir? Oder hat sie nur, oder am Ende kommt raus, war gar kein Vampir. Sie hat gerade so eine Vampirphase. Kann auch sein, ja, das ist gar keiner Sinn. Und dann natürlich so ein bisschen dieses leicht Surreale, sie ging hoch in die Küche. Ich finde, das hat schon so was. Uncanny Valley. Ja, genau, wo sind wir hier? Ist das ab jetzt schon eine Traumwelt? Ist das so eine Alice im Wunderland-Situation? Es ist wirklich Uncanny Valley, sie ging nach oben in die Küche, es ist alles so, oder sie ein Vampir, oben in die Küche, wir hängen die oben drinnen. Ach so, weil sie in der Gruft ist, weil sie in der Gruft ist, unten im Keller. Nein, ihre Mutter hängt oben an der Decke, wie so eine Wildermaus, gönnt sich einen Kaffee. Gönnt sich einen Kaffee, Fallschirm die Tasse halten. Ja, genau. Gutes Bild, weil du drehst das erste Bild und siehst die normal mit der Tasse, die falsch rum ist und dann dreht sich die Kamera mit dem Soundeffekt. Boah, es ist so, ich finde es so lustig. Das ist ja fantastisch. Diese Geschichten. Es ist ja so geil. Also für Leute, die jetzt gerade dazukommen sind, wir haben das schon mal gemacht, wir haben Geschichten vorgelesen aus unserer Kindheit. Ja. Da ist schon Gold dabei, also es ist so interessant, weil Kinder erzählen ja auch super langweilig Geschichten, also wenn Lasse, wie war es im Kindergarten, ja es war toll, dann war da Hendrik und dann haben wir zusammen gespielt im Essen, wie Essen, ja war und man hat Essen fallen gelassen und dann gespielt und dann, es werden ganz viele Dinge aufgemacht, es wird viel abgelenkt. Ja, und dann war der Hund, der kam zu uns und Frau Breitenbach meinte, die Mathe ist um zwei Uhr. Warum ist Hund, warum hast du den Hund erwähnt gerade? Dann sind wir reingegangen und dann war die Heizung ist ausgefallen und dann war noch Sport. Warum, ja. Okay, aber ist auch geil, also wie reagierst du darauf, wenn dein Kind dir so eine Geschichte gibt? Also sagst du, okay, cool, spannend. Also ich glaube, das ist eine grosse Herausforderung, wenn du Elternteil bist und sowas liest und wirklich... Generell bei diesen Kunstwerken, ich sag mal so, auch diese Bilder, also du kriegst ein Bild geschenkt oder sowas. Kinder malen viel und dann kriegst du das und die sind ja nie schön. Ich finde die immer hässlich. Ich finde die immer hässlich. Also immer hässlich. Selbst bei begabten Kindern denkt man, das ist trotzdem hässlich. Du kannst gar nicht, das ist kein Handwerk. Beherrschst du? Nee, aber ich finde das wirklich sehr spannend. Man weiß nicht genau. Die Uhr schlieg sechs Uhr ist, glaube ich, einer der bedeutendsten Sätze der deutschen Literaturgeschichte. Die Uhr schlieg sechs Uhr ist so geil, weil sechs Uhr ja auch zeigt, dass du hast es verpasst oder so. Also es geht ja um sechs Uhr los. Die Uhr schlieg sechs. Fantastisch, ey. Also diese Spannungsbögen, die nicht, also man merkt, ich habe schon mal ein Buch, wurde mit vorgelesen, wo ich beeindruckt zu sein schien von der Spannung. Eine Gestalt lief weg oder sowas. Und ich war beeindruckt von dem Mysterium. Genau, ich mache so ein paar Freizeichen auf. Manche lasse ich aber nicht, ich halte es selber nicht aus. Manche werden sofort beantwortet. Und ich finde, es ist eigentlich so eine Dramaturgie-Masterclass, wo man merkt, wie man es nicht machen sollte. Ja, genau.
So eine Gestalt lief davon, ein Vampir, eines Vampirs.
Das war ein Vampir. Bevor ihr euch gerade selber wundert, was das für eine Gestalt ist, es war ein Vampir, lasst euch sagen, man merkt, dass es ein Kind war, weil das Kind selber es nicht aushält.
Vor allem, man muss ja auch wirklich sagen, ein Vampir ist ein denkbar schlecht gewählter Bösewicht für diese Situation. Weil sie geht jetzt zu ihrer Mutter und sagt, ich habe einen Vampir gesehen, bist du dir sicher? Weil es ist letzten Endes ein Vampir. Ein Vampir ist ein Typ mit langen Zähnen und einem Umhang. Wenn die Mutter sagt, du hast einen Vampir gesehen, dann sagt sie, ja, also da würde man jemandem sagen, musst du zum Arzt, weil ein Vampir ist so normal vom Aussehen her. Die Mutter auch, direkt sagt sie, ich will sowieso zum Arzt gehen. Ja, wenn sie sagt, ich habe einen Werwolf gesehen oder sowas, wo man sagt, okay, das ist wirklich Quatsch. Oder ich habe Bigfoot gesehen. Aber wenn sie, ich habe einen Vampir gesehen, ah okay, da hatte jemand lange Zähne oder was auch immer so. Das ist einfach. Wie laut hat sich die Mutter denn oben in einem der vielen Stockwerke oben in der Küche einen Kaffee gegönnt, dass sie die Klingel nicht gehört hat, aber auch. Also hat er geklingelt, das war ja keine Einbildung. Also, welche Mutter gönnt sich einen Kaffee, wenn die Tochter gerade zum Pfadfinderabend abgeholt wird? Und schon zu spät. Sie müsste eigentlich, müsste sie Nele dahin gefahren haben, stattdessen gönnt die sich einen Kaffee. Gönnt die sich im Trinstoffen Kaffee in der Küche? Ich glaub das alles nicht. Also wirklich, also die Mutter finde ich eine spannende Figur, weil die natürlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen die Dramaturgie aufbaut, für, na du bildest jetzt nur ein, es gibt keine Vampire und Nele ist alleine und am Ende hat sie doch recht und so. Das kennt man ja auch, das lief zumindest gut, da habe ich bei Young Stephan zumindest, okay, das ist auch so, wie man es erwartet. Ich finde grammatikalisch, ich finde klare Sätze, ich bringe klar rüber, was ich meine, ich finde auch den Detailgrad nicht so schlecht, es ist halt antidramaturgisch AR, aber ich finde auch die Vampire nicht schlecht gewählt als Bösewicht in einer Pfadfinder-Storyline, denn das ist ja jetzt eigentlich der spannende Aspekt, den ich gerne noch gelesen hätte, sie kommt auf dieses Lager, sie hat schon Besuch bekommen von dieser Gestalt eines Vampires und ist jetzt an diesem Pfadfinderlager und nachts treiben ja bekanntlich Vampire ihr Unwesen.
Ja, wusste Stefan denn schon, was das bedeutet mit dem Lila Rauch oder war das etwas, was er aufgebaut hat und dann entweder unerwähnt? Ja, also ist es, wo er sagt, ah ja, am Ende taucht auch lila Rauch dann auf und alle anderen wissen gar nicht, was das bedeutet. Aber Nele sagt, nein, lila Rauch bedeutet Vampir und alle, ach Vampire gibt es nicht. Oder ist es eher so ein, was könnte passieren, Rauch, nee, lila Rauch. Du stellst die große George R. R. Martin, StephenFrage, bist du Platter oder Platter? Und Stephen King ist ja bekannt dafür, sich eine Prämisse auszudenken, ein Set auf Characters auszudenken und die sozusagen aufs Brett zu stellen und dann zu gucken, was passiert und was wäre jetzt das Coolste und immer im Moment überlegt, was wäre jetzt das Spannendste und die sozusagen, ja, ihren figuren und aus den figuren heraus dem freien lauf lässt das ende wird dann lame und man sich denkt wo ist das hin an irgendwo ja aber teilweise ja oder unzusammenhängend oder seltsam oder so und george r martin ist glaube ich einer der dann immer schon sehr genau weiss wie das ende das buch zumindest oder und sehr genau nach vorne, weshalb du natürlich befriedigende Enden schaffen kannst, weil du schon sehr weit vorne Dinge plantest, die du später ernten kannst. Ja, und wo würdest du Stefan einordnen? Ich weiß nicht, ob er da schon bereit war für diese Liste. Ich glaube, wenn, dann ist er Platter, ich weiß nicht, ob das Wort überhaupt ist, aber ich glaube nicht, dass er wusste, was Lilaner Rauch bedeutet. Ich glaube, er hat viele kleine Mysteryboxes aufgemacht und wusste selber noch nicht, was da drin ist, wenn man die aufmacht. Mutter gönnt, ja, ist schon nicht schlecht. Diese Mutter, ey. Er betont die Ruhe der Mutter, während die Nele selber so gehänzt und in Panik ist.
Und währenddessen gönnt sich die Mutter einen Kaffee, das ist ein Kontrast.
Die gönnt sich erstmal einen Kaffee, ey. Die gönnt sich einfach einen.
Wahnsinn.
So müssen auch Erwachsene aus den Augen eines Kindes wirken.
Die lieben Kaffee.
Das ist das Beste, was es für Erwachsene gibt.
Ich finde die Trennung sehr gut.
Das ist Kaffee, das ist so, ich als Kind, ich mag Snoopy, ich mag Vampire, ich mag malen und Erwachsene mögen Kaffee. Das ist so, ah ja okay, was kann der Erwachsene machen, was er mag. Ich mag aber auch so machtmäßig, dass sie oben ist, finde ich gut. Ja, okay. Ich hätte das in der Küche nicht gebraucht, aber dass sie oben am Kaffee trinken ist. Wir schauen oben, die Eltern, die Machtleute, wir gucken hoch, wir sind klein, die kleinen Kinder, das macht sie ja noch kleiner und insignificant, da unten zu stehen, ohne Kaffee. Das macht sie so erwachsen und so erhaben und das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Es ist so schade, aber du bist dir sicher, dass es da auffällt, es gibt irgendwo einen zweiten Teil oder so. Ich erinnere mich auch nicht, dass sie jemand geschrieben haben, was nicht unbedingt was bedeutet, aber ich glaube, ich habe da nicht weiter geschrieben. Schade, ich bin sehr gespannt, was du da noch ausgräbst, vor allem natürlich deine Kronerde. Ja, das können wir mal, den Epos. Den Epos, der wahrscheinlich 14 Zeilen lang ist oder so, aber auch nicht viel länger. Weil man hat ja dann noch nicht so viel Geduld. Also ich find's extrem erstaunlich als Kind, dass du auf eigene Faust sagst, ich schreib ne Geschichte, aber am Ende ist es auch nur ne Viertelgeschichte irgendwie, aber immerhin, da ist schon spannend aber wo wir gerade bei so grob bei meinem herr der ringe-eposte neulich hat jemand eine sehr gute frage gestellt zu meinem umfeld wo ich lange darüber nachgedacht habe und auch keine und dich als herr der ringe-fan fragen wollte weil jetzt auch endlich mal lohnt sich diese um weihnachten rum neujahrsahrswechsel herum, so grob, finde ich das total toll, immer die Drei-Heil-Ringe-Filme zu gucken. Total, ich mache das toll. Komplettes Making-of, schau mir alle an. Und da kann man richtig viel Zeit mit verbringen und es ist auch, wenn man sich wie wir auch für Filme interessiert und für machen interessiert, diese Dokus sind auch so fantastisch. Alles ganz, ganz toll. So, dann gibt es ja diese Szene, ich meine, es ist im zweiten Film, die zwei Türme, wo Mary und Pippin gefangen genommen werden von den Uruk-Kai. Und dann sagt der eine Uruk-Kai, grob einer der Orks, ja, also sie sind ja Halb-Orks oder whatever, die mit Bilwis-Menschen gekreutzt sind, was weiss ich. So, und dieser eine sagt dann, die fangen die und sagt, endlich wieder Fleisch auf dem Menü. Oder Englisch, finally meat on the menu, meats back on the menu. Woher wissen Orks, was ein Menü ist? weil das macht so viel speisekarte ja Eine Speisekarte. Okay, interessante Frage, habe ich so gar nicht mitgerechnet, aber ja, Meats back on the menu. Woher wissen Orks Meats back on the menu, sagt ein Ork, weil er schon mal in einem Restaurant saß, wo es eine Speisekarte gibt, in welchen... Und dann... Was hat er an? Menu, auch dieser Zeit. Zeitplan, ja, also sowas gibt es heute, was ist heute das Menu, sowas, ja, heute gibt es also eher mal einen kleinen Gartensalat als Vorspeise, dann gibt es so eine Kürbissuppe und dann gibt es Hobbitfleisch. Ich finde das aber so, die Vorstellung, weil ich habe mir Mordor immer als ein Land vorgestellt, ein Gebiet vorgestellt, wo, weiß ich nicht, Schwefel, Lavagestein und dann so ein paar Orkhütten, wo dann vielleicht mal irgendwie so ein Kessel braut. Ja, ja, mit so Schlacke einfach, mit so Dreckwasser. Und dann essen die sich selber oder whatever. Aber ich habe mir jetzt nicht so eine Taverne vorgestellt, wo es dann so eine Hey Schätzchen, was darf es sein für dich? So eine Ork-Dame. Oh, was ist denn heute auf dem Menu? Was gibt es denn heute? So eine Ork-Dame, die so in so einem Ork-Kleidchen dann da rumläuft und dann so, weiß ich nicht, so einen Humpen, den Bier hinstellt. Spielen die Karten? Was machen Orks? Ich habe so eine Faszination für Orks. Ja, es ist schwierig und es ist natürlich auch so die Frage, mögen die das oder wenn die jetzt sagen, okay, ich habe hier einen netten Bauernhof irgendwie mit Blumen und Kürbissen, würden die sagen, oh ne, ist offensichtlich besser. Das ist ja immer die grosse Frage bei so Fandys-Universen, warum leben die immer in so einer Höllenwelt? Ich mein, bei Mordor ist es natürlich so ein bisschen, weil Orks kein Sonnenlicht vertragen. Das heißt, du musst den Himmel verdunkeln, deswegen wächst da auch nichts, lebt da nichts. Ja, das erklärt natürlich, warum die kein Blumenbeet oder so ein Hochgarten haben, so ein Hochbeet. Ja, so ein paar Reben. Das verstehe ich wohl, weil die halt nachts seien. Aber so, ich verstehe nicht, warum die jetzt nicht Tavernen oder auch das gute Leben bevorzugen, so Hedonismus, aber da sind es auch nicht wirklich, sind ja keine, sind es Lebewesen Lebewesen? Ja, doch. Mit einem schlagenden Herzen. Ja, ja. Wofür schlägt deren Herz? Du kannst dir ja gerne mal Rings of Power anschauen. Hab ich schon. Da wird das ja so ein bisschen, da gibt es ja diesen Ader, der dann sozusagen sich als Vater der Orks versteht, der sagt ja, die wurden mal von Sauron erschaffen. Aber Sauron ist doch ein Maja oder so. Ich habe diese Videos jetzt geguckt. Oder ein Vala. Jedenfalls, die können kein Leben mehr schaffen. Genau, die Frage ist, was ist, wenn ein Ultrabösewicht schafft böse Kreaturen, dann wird der Bösewicht aber besiegt. Was ist mit den Kreaturen? Haben die ein Recht auf Leben? Haben die ein Recht auf ihre Natur, auch wenn sie böse Kreaturen sind? Wie läuft das? Das ist ja die, finde ich, nicht uninteressante Frage, die Rings of Power da stellt. Was macht man, wenn man eine Spezies an bösen oder verkommenen Kreaturen hat? Müssen die alle weg oder dürfen die irgendwie leben, haben die ihr eigenes Land irgendwo, dürfen die irgendwo alleine wohnen? Ja, was machen die denn dann? Haben die Häuschen? Ja, das ist die Frage. Ich finde, das ist alles in diesem Meats Back on the Menu-Satz. Ja, die mögen halt Gewalt. Meats Back on the Menu. Ja, Back. Hast du schon ausgesucht? Ich überlege noch, soll ich den Ratteneintopf nehmen oder die Augencreme? Ich weiss auch nicht, ich bin gerade eher bei Trollhirn. Trollhirn soll hier ganz lecker sein, aber das ist aber gerade nicht die Saison, ne? Das muss schon, ich weiss nicht. Ich weiss, Flughirn. Jetzt wird mit den Adlern gebracht. Ja. Hast du es schon gehört? Hast du es schon gehört? Was denn? Sauron will uns losschicken. Was, wirklich? In den Krieg, ja. Ach nein, Schatz. Ja. Aber dann sag auch diesmal, dass es ein bisschen zu viel ist. Hab ich schon. Du warst beim letzten Mal schon dabei, als es hier gegen Helmsklam ging. Ja, du weisst ja, wie das gelaufen ist. Schön, dass du dann noch nach Hause gekommen bist, aber jetzt beim nächsten Mal musst du auch mal auf den Tisch hauen und sagen das war was hemsklamm ja bitte ach so ja genau ich hätte einmal die cola und einmal das trollhirn bitte ich hätte gern die eine grosse spezi bitte und dann hätte ich gerne einmal die fledermausflügel bitte ja das ist nur noch umentschieden. Ach, die finde ich auch gut. Ja, die mag ich immer ganz gerne. Die Badwings. Die machen die hier immer so in Hobbit-Fett. Stimmt. Ja, das ist ganz nett. Nein, aber Schatz, wirklich, du musst da mal was sagen. Dankeschön. Ja, danke. Du musst da wirklich mal was sagen. Du arbeitest so viel in letzter Zeit. Ich weiß, aber was soll ich denn sagen? Ja, sag halt, nee, ich bin halt, ich habe keine, ich hab gerade, brauche ich ein bisschen Zeit für mich, ich brauche ein bisschen Zeit für mich. Ich brauche das Geld. Ja. Geld? Ja, doch. Schleckt unser Herz? Was sind wir? Mein Herz schlägt schon lange nicht mehr, Schatz. Ja, das merke ich aber seit Tagen. Also wirklich, ich finde das eine spannende Frage, der ist so viel impliziert, da ist so viel Welt. Ja, es ist so geil, es ist auch wirklich, Herr der Ringe natürlich absolutes Meisterwerk, keine Frage, aber wenn man so oft schaut, natürlich fallen einem Dinge auf, wenn man sich fragt. Meets back on the menu. Meine Lieblingsszenen ist hier mittlerweile die Ringgeister in Bre, dieser Prank von Aragon, der jedes Mal, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, weniger Sinn ergibt.
Also wirklich auch gar nicht. Also zu sagen, also grundsätzlich auch diese Dramaturgie, wenn wir heute über Dramaturgie reden. Genau, heute die Dramaturgie-Folge. Du weisst, Gollum wurde gefoltert und sagt, Baggins, Beutlin. Nee. Auenland, Beutlin. Also, der Zuschauer weiss, oh, die wissen Beutlin, Frodo Beutlin.
Frodo läuft dann vor den Nazgul weg und meldet sich dann an im Gasthaus als Unterberg. Frodo hat also verstanden, dass sein Name ein Risiko ist und dass der Feind seinen Namen kennen könnte. Dann feiern die da abends und dann wird Dramaturgie aufgebaut mit, Mary und Pippin sagen irgendwann frodo baggins that's my friend frodo baggins oh nein der zuschauer weiß oh gott hier ist hier ist eine gefahr weil die nehmen diese gefahr nicht ernst so also wir wissen name unterberg zimmer die sagen jetzt im raum aber den echten namen beut. Und jetzt kommen die Ringgeister an und fragen an der Rezeption. Entschuldigung, eine Frage, ist schon spät. Nee, also muss diese Klingel sein. Genau. Ding, ding, ding. Nee, Check-in ist nur bis 18 Uhr. Nee, ich hätte nur eine Frage, Entschuldigung. Es schlägt schon sechs Uhr. Nein, Entschuldigung, ich habe eine Frage, Entschuldigung, geht ganz schnell, geht ganz schnell. Was sind Sie denn? Entschuldigung, ja, gut, ja, keine Sorge. Haben Sie das Tor, wir haben das Tor eingetragen. Ich habe das Tor eingetreten, ja, wir haben das Tor eingetreten, korrekt. Dann stehen Sie, dann stehen Sie mit diesen riesen Lederdingern und Metallhandschuhen und fragen eine Rezeption. Und, Entschuldigung, ist hier jemand eingecheckt? Ist ein bisschen höflicher, wenn Sie die Kapuzone nehmen. Geht leider nicht, leider nicht. Hautverletzung? Ist hier jemand eingecheckt namens Beutlin? Nein, Unterberg hat eingecheckt. Ach so. Okay, nee, Jungs, Unterberg suchen wir ja nicht. So, und jetzt ist die Frage, gehen die jetzt und dann sagen die, so und jetzt, ja dann nehmen wir uns noch ein Bier, oder? Nehmen wir uns ein Bier. So, und dann gehen die an die Theke und sagen, ach, dieser Beutlin, Mensch, wo ist der? Und jemand aus der Theke, weil da wurde er vorher in der Name genannt, sagt, Beutlin, Moment mal, hier hat vorher jemand über Beutlin geredetet. Was, Heinrich, was, was, hier, Beutlin? Also, weil die Gefahr ist ja in den Leuten, die da in der Taverne gesessen sind, ach, Beutlin, doch hier, ah, dann lass uns jetzt mal auf irgendein Zimmer gehen oder lass uns jetzt auf das Zimmer gehen von dem Unterberg und dann gehen die in irgendein Zimmer, weil sie haben ja den Namen nicht und sehen ein Zimmer voller gefüllter Betten und sagen, lass uns die alle abstechen. Ja, aber wir wissen ja nicht, ob das das richtige Zimmer ist. Ne, lass uns trotzdem alle abstechen. also ich kann mir zu einem vorstellen es ist das ultimative böse die sind das ultim es macht gar keinen Sinn, also machen wir uns nichts vor ich habe immer so gedacht, die spüren also wenn man die Szene guckt, chronologisch, denke ich, ah die spüren wo Frodo ist, wegen Ring oder Fantasy Epos und dann stechen sie auf sie ein aber dann waren sie es ja nicht also spüren sie ihn dann doch nicht und vor allem die Frage ist also die Grundfrage, die sich mir immer stellt, ist, warum machen die diesen Prank? Weil wenn die die Nasogol einfach einen leeren Raum gefunden hätten, hätten sie gesagt, ach so okay, die sind gar nicht hier. Aber wenn sie diesen präparierten Raum finden, denken sie, ah, die sind hier irgendwo und die sind einfach im Raum nebenan. aber dass sie da irgendwo sind wissen die ja eh also die erfrag, waren ja Halblinge, also wahrscheinlich wird dieser Hexenmeister hingegangen sein, North School Guy, fragt, waren die Halblinge, haben die Halblinge eingecheckt, ja, Unterberg, Zimmer, bla bla bla, und die gehen dann dahin. Ach so, du meinst sie gehen gar nicht nach dem Namen und diese ganze Namenscharade davor war völlig irrelevant. Nee, diese Namenscharade soll nur sagen, Mary und Pippin checken nicht den Ernst der Lage. Aber ist ja auch nicht schlimm, weil die gehen ja gar nicht nach dem Namen, die Nazgul. Also haben die ja auch dann rückwirkend gar nichts falsch gemacht. Die Hobbits fallen ja eh auf. Sind ja Halbling, haben Halbling eingecheckt. Okay, also du meinst, die Nazgul checken schon so weit, ah, das sind Halbling. Das haben die ja schon gesehen. Ja, ja, okay. Die haben die ja schon gesehen. Dann fragen die, wo sind die Halblinge. Dann hat ein Herr Unterberg Halbling eingecheckt. Wo man auch mal, finde ich, die Integrität des Gastwirts hinterfragen kann. Wenn neun dunkle Gestalten mit riesigen Schwertern und Panzerhandschuhen vor dir stehen, die gerade das Tor eingerannt haben und fragen, Entschuldigung, eine Frage.
Sorry.
Es sind hier irgendwo Halblinge eingecheckt.
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ach so. Ja, passend auf, folgendes. Wir würden Sie dann umbringen.
Okay, also sehe ich es richtig? Meine Integrität steht meinem Leben gegenüber.
Korrekt, genau so ist es. Ein moralisches Dilemma, könnte man sagen. Alles klar. Genau, Zimmer neun. Alles klar, danke. Und dann gehen Sie hoch. Wir würden uns aber eine gute Bewertung freuen. Dann gehen Sie hoch, stechen und kommen ja wieder runter. Ja, da war jetzt gar niemand drin. Ich hab, was soll ich sagen, das ist Zimmer neun. Naja, aber das, also finden Sie das lustig? Erwin als der Prankster. Also finden Sie, finden Sie das witzig, unsere Zeit zu verschwenden? Nee, gar nicht witzig. Ich habe den Zimmer 9 gegeben. Wir dachten da, wir hätten sie gefunden, und dann haben wir alle drauf eingestochen, und dann war da gar niemand. Dann haben wir all ihre Betten und Laken kaputt gemacht umsonst. Was? Ja, warum machen sie das denn? Die Kaution kriegt der Unterbegermann nicht zurück. Gut, also, also. Aber Moment, genau, das heißt, die kommen runter, sagen, da war ja niemand. Die haut ja nicht ab, weil sie denken, sie haben... Genau, und dann gehen die einfach wieder. Weil es gibt ja dann keine Szene, wie die ihn Brereda noch da verfolgen, sondern der Plan hat ja geklappt. Das verstehe ich nicht. Sucht weiter nach denen, weil die sind ja da, das wissen sie ja. Genau, euch wurde ja gerade ein Prank gelegt. Nee, auch, aber alle in diesem Ort sagen, ja, Halblinger waren hier gerade noch. Ja, ja, und die gehen aber einfach wieder so, das ist also vor allem, also das ist natürlich eine Lorefrage, aber weiss Aragorn, was die Nazgul sind? Weil der denkt sich, ah krass, wir werden gerade verfolgt von, ja, einer Art, einer Art wie ich selber, ein verführter Menschenkönig und Aragorn will ja gerade nicht der Menschenkönig werden, vielleicht weil er irgendwie den Machtmissbrauch ahnt oder weil er die Verantwortung nicht nimmt und er weiss, das ist quasi das Gegenbild zu mir, das kann aus mir werden, wenn ich der Macht verfalle, die prank ich, oder?
Also die, ne, oder? Jungs, Jungs, hey, hey, hey, nee, nee, im Ernst, im Ernst und alle so, nee, komm, lass uns gehen, streiche, bitte, lass uns gehen, lass uns gehen, schreiche und streiche so, nee, nee, komm, weißt du, was wir machen, wir nehmen alle Decken und stecken die, und nee, wir holen Heu, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, wir holen Heu, wir holen, nee, ohne Witz, wir holen Heu, wir holen Heu. Und so ein Eimer, stehen wir oben auf die Tür und dann kommen sie rein und dann so, ist Wasser über dem. Und ja genau, die haben so die Hobbit so Todesangst, weil diese Riesengestalten da kommen, aber ehrlich gesagt, trotz Trash-Talking gerade wieder richtig Bock auf diese Filme bekommen. Absolut, und die Szene funktioniert ja auch, emotional ist sie total gut, auch das mit den Namen funktioniert, wenn du denkst, oh scheiße, jetzt sind sie in Gefahr und oh gein, jetzt haben sie so ein Streicher und Shit, die haben sie in Gefahr. Aber es ergibt nicht wirklich Sinn, was wieder heißt, Filme basieren nicht auf Logik. Nee, Zaubertricks. Null, es ist alles Zaubertricks, man sagt dem schlä schlägt das Film, weil er nicht logisch ist. Nee, die meisten Filme sind komplett unlogisch und es interessiert niemanden, weil es emotional total funktioniert. Und deswegen funktioniert es auch. Aber es ist ja, fantastisch. Also ich habe jetzt wieder richtig Bock bekommen. Geil. Ja, also ja, gut, große Dramaturgiefolge. Manche Sachen machen keinen Sinn, ist völlig okay. Es geht nur darum, eine emotionale Connection zu haben und emotionale Köder auszuwerfen, an die du andockst und dann bist du drin. Du bist so sehr in dem Charakter drin, man verzeiht so viel. Ah, schon gut. Ja, super. Ich möchte noch eine ganz kurze, ja sagen wir mal, Ansage machen. Also, also folgendes. Ja, wie mache ich das jetzt? Also, ich rede jetzt über ein Thema, okay? Und dann, also möchte ich damit aber jemanden direkt ansprechen, aber ich möchte gar nicht sagen, wen direkt. Okay. Okay? Also ich habe nämlich ein gewisses Problem. Okay. Es ist so ein klassisches irgendwie Hosenstall ist offen, sage ich, sage ich es nicht Problem.
Okay.
Okay? Und deswegen glaube ich, wenn ich jetzt über dieses Problem im Allgemeinen rede, könnte vielleicht jemand sich persönlich angesprochen fühlen. Aber ich spreche die Person gar nicht persönlich an, sondern ich rede allgemein jetzt über das Thema. Mit diesem Vorklapp habe ich noch mehr das Gefühl, du meinst eine Person selber. Tue ich auch. Ganz klar, tue ich auch direkt, aber ich werde jetzt so darüber sprechen, dass es ein allgemeines Ding ist und ich möchte einfach nur eine. Du sagst, du meinst eine Person selber. Tu ich auch. Ganz klar, tu ich auch direkt, aber ich werde jetzt so
darüber sprechen, dass es ein allgemeines Ding ist
und ich möchte einfach nur eine...
Du sagst, du machst eine mysteriöse Gestalt
läuft weg ein Vampir.
Ich möchte einfach nur eine Information
allgemein in die Welt bringen,
aber ich glaube, für eine Person
ist diese Information ganz besonders
relevant. Bin ich diese Person?
Ich rede allgemein über ein Thema.
Und zwar, weil die moderne Technik, gerade Social Media, da gibt es ja viele Funktionen, die vielleicht gar nicht jeder kennt.
Und man gar nicht so genau weiss, was eigentlich im Internet für Spuren hinterlassen werden.
Und deswegen möchte ich einfach mal ganz allgemein einen Fakt aussprechen. Wenn man auf Instagram ein Real, also dieses kleine Videoclip, wenn man das liked, dann können Leute, denen man folgt oder die dir folgen, das sehen. Das ist spannend, ja. Okay? Und wirklich, niemand ist direkt angesprochen. Nein, nein. Nur ganz allgemein, vielleicht mal dran denken, dass wenn man ein Reel liked, dass das potenziell andere Leute, mit denen man über Instagram verbunden ist, sehen können. Weil wir alle kennen unsere Reels bei Instagram. Natürlich erwischt uns Instagram bei unseren niedersten Trieben und das ist okay, das ist völlig okay. Man kriegt lustige Sachen reingespült, man kriegt lustige süße Tiere reingespült, man kriegt sexy Content reingespült, man liked Leute sehen. Für Spä, genau. Für Spä, hm? Nee, genau. Ist ja gut, also kann ja guter Content sein, kann ja geschmackvoll sein. Kann ja geschmackvoll und sexy zugleich sein. Ja. Man liked das. Leute kriegen dann vielleicht, wir wissen ja nicht genau, wie diese Algorithmen funktionieren. Niemand weiß es. Manchmal sieht man aber ja, wenn man auch das gleiche Video bekommt, ah, das gefällt. Genau, und man versteht, ah, der Algorithmus denkt, ah, das ist ein Kumpel von mir, ähm, bekannter, würde ich sagen, bekannter von mir, den ich kennengelernt habe, den ich sehr mag, von dem man wirklich, wirklich nicht erwarten würde, dass er diese Art Content genießt. Aber ich weiß nicht, macht Instagram das, schickt Instagram dir, weil es ihm gefällt, dir diese Videos in die Teilen rein, aber, ähm, ich glaube, das ist bestimmt ein Faktor. Oder du kriegst ja auch manchmal ein sexy, cooles, hohes Video reinspülen. Und es kann ja zu viel das Gleiche sein. Ich meine, ihr macht, also unabhängig davon, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert, selbst wenn jemand das gleiche Video einfach aus Zufall bekommt, sieht er ja, dass unten euer Like da drin steht. Absolut. Und ich habe ja auch gar nichts gegen sexy Content und das kann ja jeder anschauen, kein Problem ist ja eine Sache. Ich möchte einfach nur, und mir geht es gar nicht um eine Verurteilung oder Einordnung, mir geht es schlicht um die Information und wenn jemand sagt, ey, ich like das, ich mag das, kein Problem, jeder kann das sehen, ist ja völlig in Ordnung. Aber manchmal, und das ist nur eine Interpretation, habe ich gefühl dass leute das nicht wissen und dann möchte ich das jetzt einfach mal nur gesagt es ist dass du hast ein basilikum blatt zwischen den zähnen genau des internets leute passt auf ihr hinterlasst im internet spuren ja dann viele ganz ehrlich zu sein ich bin mir auch oft unsicherlässt und was nicht, weil du kannst ja Reels zum Beispiel speichern oder in Ordner ablegen. Das ist soweit, hoffe ich nicht, öffentlich. Schaut mal, klicken wir bei Florentin oben auf die gespeicherten Clips. Nein, aber das nur mal so am Rande, weil es ist ein Bekannter von mir, den ich kennengelernt habe und der wirklich ein super lieber Typ ist und auch nur so Hobby-Sachen postet und so und irgendwie total nett ist und lieb und sich um alle kümmert und dann die heftigsten Sachen einfach liked. Weil Instagram, man muss ja sagen, wenn man da mal in dieses Rabbit Hole geht, das geht ja richtig tief, es gibt anscheinend auch kaum sowas wie Nacktheitsregeln. Bei Instagram Reels. Ist das nicht immer die Idee, dass Nippel zentiert werden? Genau, aber das wird teilweise, sagen wir mal, recht clever umgangen. Also eine Art Reel, die ich dadurch immer wieder gesehen habe, ist zum Beispiel, jemand sagt, ich habe hier was im Keller gefunden, was ist das denn? Komisches Objekt, keine Ahnung, kann mir jemand sagen, was das ist? Und es ist, sagen wir mal, eine Kugel, die sehr reflektiert, eine sehr spiegelnde Oberfläche. Und die Person, die das in der Hand hat, ist halt nackt. Aber es ist ein ganz harmloses Video, so wie wenn jemand einen Löffel zeigt, guck mal, was ist das für ein Löffel, ist das ein Teelöffel oder ist das ein Esslöffel? Das heißt, das ist die spezielle Interesse, leicht begleitete Frauen räumen Keller aus oder sind auf Schatzsuche. Das ist dieses sehr spezielle Interesse, was alle haben. Und ich denke mir so, ist das ein echtes Loophole, zu sagen, man darf Nacktheit zeigen, solange es sich in einem Löffel spiegelt? Also ist es, wo Instagram sagt, fuck, die sind gut. Wir lieben Löffel. Fuck, wir lieben... Jerry, Jerry, Jerry, Jerry, wir können jetzt keine Löffel verbieten. Hey, stopp, nein, nein, wir können jetzt keine Löffel verbieten. Uns würde so viel Traffic verloren gehen, wenn wir jetzt Löffel verbieten würden. 80 Prozent unseres Traffics basieren auf Löffeln und anderen reflektierenden Oberflächen. Ja, aber Moment mal, du meinst, weil sich darin nackte Körperspiegel? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Du bist ein genauso großer Löffelfan wie ich. Ich liebe Löffel und reflektierende Oberflächen im Allgemeinen. Ich bin ein genauso großer Fan. Es kann doch nicht nur an den, das, na aber, na aber, aber. Zeig mal deine Likes, zeig mal die letzten Sachen, die du geliked hast. Nein. Ne, zeig mal gerade, nur damit wir mal gucken können. Ja, ne, ich bin auch gerade, ich habe gar nicht, ich lache nicht.
Ja, okay, dann schaue ich ich habe gar nicht, ich lage mich.
Ja, okay, dann schaue ich es einfach bei mir. Ich kann es ja sehen, was du likest.
Ja, hier.
Cherry, das ist doch, schau doch mal in die Reflexion.
Ja, aber schau doch mal diese mega Nippel an. Es ist halt schon.
Es ist schon interessant, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das ...
Also ich meine, es gibt ja dann immer so dieses, man lädt es hoch und dann kriegt es 10.000 Likes und dann wird es gelöscht oder so. Man hat trotzdem erreicht, was man erreichen wollte. Oder ist es wirklich ein Loophole, dass man das so macht? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das ist. Ich bin so ein Fan von, wohin sie das Internet gerade entwickelt. Es gibt auch ... Es ist mal irgendwann gescheitert, ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war, wenn man zu klar sozusagen feindselige Ranglisten, also es hat man jetzt schon auch Social Media Netzwerke, obwohl sie soziale Netzwerke sind, dürfen nicht zu viele soziale Transparenz haben. Beispiel, du darfst nicht wissen, öffentlich einsehen, wer deine Lieblingsfans sind.
Es gab irgendwie irgendwo mal bei Snapchat oder so, gab es mal diese Funktion, welche drei, die am häufigsten sich dein Content angucken. Was natürlich voll creepy ist. Und Social Media, ich meine nur, Social Media Networks sind ja auf eine Art, geht es ja um Transparenz, man postet viel von sich und so was. Aber es darf auch nicht zu transparent sein. Klar, Authentizität, Riesenthema gerade, aber es darf auch nicht zu authentisch sein. Und jetzt soll, glaube ich, Instagram macht jetzt wohl auf, dass es eine enge Freundesliste gibt, also so Freundesgruppen, und du siehst, wer in diesen Freundesgruppen drin ist. Das heisst, und sind jetzt schon viele so, haben Angst, dass es dieser Snapchat-Fuck-up wird, dass man sozusagen weiß, wer noch in dieser eigenen Freundesgruppe drin ist. Also es ist sehr spannend, was sich das gerade entwickelt, finde ich. Ist spannend auf jeden Fall. Vor allem auch, ich weiß nicht, als es bei Twitter beobachtet, also Ex heißt es jetzt, wir sind da auch nicht mehr. Also ihr könnt da auch alle abhauen, wenn ihr wenigstens noch da seid. Unser Soldier-Media-Twitter-Kanal ist dead.
Tatsächlich, ich kann da nicht mehr posten, weil man seit es Ex ist nicht mehr irgendwie mehrere Accounts gleichzeitig kontrollieren kann, ohne Mitglied zu sein.
Deswegen haben wir einfach aufgehört, da zu posten und es hat auch niemanden interessiert.
Ist auch lame, ich bin da auch nicht mehr manchmal zum Lesen und so.
Und da habe ich noch, was es ja gibt, ist halt wenn Falschmeldungen,
das ist auch, keine Ahnung,
alles ist ein bisschen undurchsichtig gerade geworden bei Ax, aber
wenn dann halt, ist auch
Elon Musk schon mal auf die Füße gefallen, er hat dann mal
irgendwie Propaganda oder so geteilt
und drunter
gibt es dann unabhängige
Institutionen, ich weiß nicht, wie unabhängig die sind,
jetzt auch ein Disclaimer, aber unten drunter schreiben die dann, nee, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so, Impfstoffe funktionieren gemäss bla bla bla bla bla.
Und das heisst, du hast manchmal dann so politische Accounts, irgendwelche Fakten teilen, in Anführungszeichen, und unten hast du dann drunter stehen, nee, eigentlich ist es so und so. Und das lustigste Beispiel dafür war neulich um Thanksgiving herum ging dieses Bild viral, was immer um Thanksgiving herum geht.
Du hast Truthähne im Kreis sitzen an einem Thanksgiving Dinner und ein Mensch hast du braun gebraten durch, köstlich in der Mitte liegen und drüber steht sowas wie Why are we doing this to them, they would never do this to us.
They would. Und darunter stand dann diese neue Factcheck, unabhängige Twitter-Nachricht, unter diesem Tweet stand, Turkeys are not vegetarians, turkeys eat mais, lizards, frocks and just about anything they can fit in their mouth. Wenn Turkeys mehr oder die technologischen Beine haben, zu färben und zu essen, die
currenten Diet zeigt, dass sie die and just about anything they can fit in their mouth. If Turkeys were larger or had the technological means to farm and eat humans, their current diet reveals they likely would. Das ist ja fantastisch. They likely would. To farm and eat, und es war diese generierte, diese computergenerierte neutrale Fekte. If they had the technology, they would eat us. If turkeys were larger and had the technological means to farm and eat humans, their current diet reveals they likely would. To farm and eat humans. Wenn sie grösser werden. Das ist auch fantastisch, wirklich. Wenn sie grösser werden. Aber welches Tier würde es nicht machen? Pflanzenfresser, also reine Herbihonen. Ja, dann so eine Raupe oder sowas. Wenn sie grösser werden. Und die Technologie. Vor allem, es braucht nicht viel Technologie, um zu farmen. Du brauchst Willenskraft und einen Zaun. Mehr brauchst du nicht. Einen Zaun musst du erst mal bauen. Naja, gut. Zaun muss man bauen. Zaun muss man bauen. Aber ich stelle mir so Turkey-Entitäten vor, so Truthähne mit so einem weisen Rad und den Flügeln. Nehmen wir auch diese weisen Hälse. Oh ja, genau, diese schlabeligen Krägen und dann so inzwischen, ich würde darauf bestehen, meinen Menschen, Freilaufmenschen zu essen.
Ja klar, also ich esse nur noch Freilaufmenschen.
Mir ist Biomensch wichtig. Diese Käfighaltung, das ist nichts für mich.
Hast du auf Ex diesen Post gesehen, wo so ganz viele Menschen am Tisch sitzen und in der Mitte einer von uns so gebacken und gebraten. Ja. Humans are not vegetarians. Humans eat mice, lizards, die heutige Diet zeigt, aber schaut euch mal um. Aber haben Menschen noch den Tierstatus? Naja, wir entscheiden das, Stefan. Guck mal, und allein diese Frage zeigt, wie überlegen wir sind, weil wir die Regeln machen. Der Truthan macht nicht die Regel, was ein Tier ist und was nicht.
Da gibt es ja auch dann diese Beispiele, angenommen, Alien kommt auf die Erde, schaut sich an, Menschen, Familie im Haus beobachtet dieses Alien und will herausfinden, was ist die dominante Spezies.
Und dann haben die Hundenfamilie und ein kleines Kind und der Hund kriegt Essen,
der Hund wird Gasse gegangen, mit dem Hund wird gespielt,
alle gehen arbeiten,
um sich Hundefutter kaufen zu können für den Hund.
Und das Eilige dann davon aus, dass der Hund die dominante Spezies ist, weil es das bessere Leben hat.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite, der Hund hat nicht Penicillin erfunden.
Ja, aber warum? Aber muss der Hund ja auch nicht.
Ja, okay, aber der Hund ist
in den Weltraum geflogen. Leica, Rest in peace, ist in den Weltraum geflogen und ... Leica? Ja. L-E-I-C-A? Ja, ich weiss nicht genau. Wie die Kamera? Leica ist ... Ja, ja. Ich weiss gar nicht genau, woran die dann gestorben ist. Ob die dann einfach verhungert irgendwann? Ich finde die kein gutes Beispiel, weil die wurde von einer Spezies in die Todgeschichte. Ja. So, aber jetzt, aber jetzt muss ich sagen, alle anderen Hunde kriegen ja ihre Menschen dazu zu überleben und haben nicht mal den Miet, Penicillin zu erfinden, weil die Menschen, sie haben Menschen dafür, die es gemacht haben. Also sie schicken nicht mal die Arbeit rein. Das sind so die Parasiten, die sich am Ende dranhängen. Ja, ja. Und ich finde das Gedankensperiment albern, aber auch lustig. Ja, es gibt auch so bei Mistkäfern, die rollen ihr so diesen Mistkäferball. Und dann gibt es aber manche Mistkäfer, die machen das nicht, sondern die warten dann, bis die anderen es gemacht haben und nehmen den weg. Das wäre es du als Musikkäfer. Wo man sich auch denkt, wer ist schlauer so, aber das ist, wo ich denke, ihr seid ein Team, Mann, ey, ihr seid, also, wenn eine andere Tierart kommt und es wegnimmt, okay, aber da denke ich mir, nee, der Mistkäfer, glaube ich, ist nicht, ist nicht Tier des Jahres, Flop des Jahres. Tier Flop des Jahres, für mich Mistkäfer, die sich andere Mistkugeln klauen. Du bist immer noch auf deiner Tauben-Vendetta unterwegs, oder was? Ja, und ich habe viel Nachrichten bekommen, dass ihr das auch so seht. Tauben benehmen sich merkwürdig, Tauben werden schwächer, werden dümmer, werden lethargisch, fliegen nicht mehr so weg, wie wir das kennen. Und in unserem Reddit, das lieben wir, reddit.com slash das Podcast UFO, gibt es auch ein Video, wie dumm sind Tauben
wirklich, eine Taube, die einfach zu einem Adler
oder was ist, ein Turmfalke oder sowas
einfach reingeht und gefressen
wird und es ist nicht nur,
also sie geht da einfach rein, sie
sieht dann auch sogar diesen
Raubvogel, der sie auch noch anguckt
und so, der Vogel auch so, äh, was?
Es sieht aus wie eine Deliveroo-Lieferung.
Der Falke denkt sich auch so, is this real life? Ist das jetzt, das Essen fliegt mir quasi in den Mund? Ja. Der dachte sich auch so, wie das, ich kann dich auch jagen, aber ich meine, er fühlt sich fast in seiner Ehre gekränkt, wenn das Beutetier zu ihm kommt. Ich bin grosses, starkes, flinkes Wesen. Ja. Du bist eine lethargische, dicke dicke kacktaube ich würde dich auch fangen wenn du wegrennen würde ich würde auch fangen wenn du nicht zu mir nach hause in meinen zehn mal zehn zentimeter käfig kommen ist in zehn kommt er da rein und ja von daher muss ich schon sagen tauben sind für mich flop des fucking jahres die sind so so dumm und Uncool und stinken und verbreiten krankheiten ratten der lüfte immer wieder ratten der luft deine top fünf ratten der lüfte eidechsen aber die frage ist gibt es noch was anderes der lüfte gibt es die eidechsen der lüfte also wenn du jetzt sagst okay die die weichtiere der lüfte die ornithologie ist sozusagen eigentlich nur eine wissenschaft der der XY der Lüfte. Was ist der Löwe der Lüfte. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, die Ornithologie ist sozusagen eigentlich nur eine Wissenschaft der XY der Lüfte. Was ist der Löwe der Lüfte? Was ist irgendwie der Wurm der Lüfte? Wer ist der Mensch der Lüfte? Was kann man da so machen? Wer ist der Mensch der Lüfte? Jesus fucking Christ. Wenn die Taube die Ratte der Lüfte ist. Also sind wir nicht auch, sind Menschen nicht Menschen der Lüfte, weil Menschen auch menschen auch durch luft so richtig gut sind wir nicht in luft so richtig gut sind wir nicht in luft ich würde sagen irgendwas was aber wo ich mir auch denke sorry fucking vögel weil es hat er jetzt geschneit recht viel und ich denke wenn es schneit dann liege ich in meinem bett und kuschelt mich richtig ein und dann mache ich manchmal auch noch das Fenster auf, so dass es ganz kalt wird und ich bin ganz kuschelig unter der Decke. Und dann denke ich mir, was machen eigentlich alle Tiere gerade? Weil irgendwo im Wald sitzt einfach so ein Reh auf dem Boden und wird eingeschneit. Und dann schüttelt sich das, die haben nix, die haben gar nix. Oder so ein Vogel sitzt irgendwie auf dem Ast und dann fällt Schnee auf ihn und der sagt, oh shit, weg damit. Kann, schläft der dann? Kopfschmerzen. Schläft der und wird komplett ein. Haben Tiere Kopfschmerzen? Das ist eine gute Frage, weiss ich. Aber so nervige, weil Juckreiz haben Tiere ja manchmal, Aber immer so ein Kopfschmerztrag.
Oh, ich steh heute nicht auf. Ohne Scheisse.
Und die liegen einfach um. Da nenne ich einen Vogel, der für mich das dümmste Tier ist, weil der baut sich ein Nest. Wie wär's mit einem Dach, du Trottel? Ich mein, du baust dir schon ein Haus und es ist am Ende einfach so ein Teller und dann sitzt er auf dein Nest und dann bist du eingeschnallt. Wo ich ja jegliche Respekt vor Tieren verloren habe, ist dieses Video, wo ein Biber, der in der Wohnung gehalten wird, einen Damm in einer Tür baut, mit Kuscheltieren oder Einrichtungsgegenständen, trägt er dann diese Tür und baut einen Damm. Biber's gonna beep. Ja, Biber's gonna do Bieber things. Aber ich frage mich, hä? weil er ist das so tief in seiner DNA drin oder Intuition, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, dass er einen Damm bauen muss, dass er das macht, obwohl er
wahrscheinlich ist er da aufgewachsen und weiß von der Existenz von Wasser nicht mal oder von, weiß ich nicht, Fluten, die dich mitreissen können, wo es Sinn macht, einen Damm zu bauen, um dann ein Haus zu bauen. so zählsam. Vertrau mir mal, vertrau mir mal gerade. Let him cook, vertrau mir mal gerade.
Ich weiss, es sieht dumm aus.
Ich lege jetzt hier mal die Pringles-Rolle, lege ich hier mal hin und die Taschentücher lege ich jetzt mal hier in die Türangel. Lass mich mal machen, lass mich mal machen. Das wird am Ende alles hinzugehen. Ich denke mir nur, am Ende des Tages hast du einen geschützten Bereich, in dem du wohnen kannst. So im besten Fall, was ich auch nicht glaube, dass diese Pringles-Pack-VPackung... Es ist immer gut, einen Damm zu haben. Wir haben Wände aus Beton. Wir haben Betonwände. Wenn hier das große Hochwasser kommt, dann willst du einen Damm, glaub mir. Glaub mir. Also das willst du nicht, wenn dann irgendwie Wasser kommt. Beste Pointe wäre, ist irgendwie in Hamburg, Jahrhundertflut und die eine Familie, die den Biber hat, hat überlebt, weil er als einziges diese Flut zurückgehalten hat. Ja, kann schon sein, kann schon sein. Die wissen schon, was los ist. Deswegen Biber des Jahres. Biber des Jahres ist der Biber. Okay, alles klar. Wunderbar, dann haben wir das auch geklärt. Damit sind wir eigentlich bereit für ein fantastisches neues Jahr und wir freuen uns darauf. Es wird natürlich weitergehen, das Podcast-Ufo begibt sich in ein neues Jahr. In unser zehnjähriges Jahr. In unser zehnjähriges Jahr, erzähl doch mal kurz. Wir haben 2014 angefangen, ich glaube im November oder so, das heißt wir haben nächstes Jahr zehn Jahre, das große Jubiläumsjahr. Da machen wir einen schönen Weihnachtsmarkt, oder? Mit Glühwein und Plätzchen, da machen wir was Schönes, überlegen wir uns. Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein, haut rein, habt noch eine ganz schöne Woche, wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, bis nächstes Mal, wir freuen uns und würden über die nächste Zeit, wir heben ab, ja wir heben ab und freuen uns auf.
Ich will machen keine Pause, wir machen auch einfach keine Pause, Ciao. Es hört nie wieder auf.
Macht's gut.